So this is game theory,
economics one 59,
if you're here for art history,
you're either in the wrong room or stay anyway.
Maybe this is the right room,
but this is game theory.
Okay?
Uh,
you should have for handouts,
everyone should have for handouts.
That is a legal release for multiple minutes.
Uh,
about the videoing.
There is a syllabus which is approved in his syllabus.
It's also online and there are two games labeled game one and game two.
Can I get you all to look at game one and start thinking about it?
And while you're thinking about it,
I'm hoping you can multitask or bets.
Oh,
I'll describe a bit about the class and we'll get a bit of admin under our
belts.
But please try and look at somebody not looking at because they are using it as
a fan here.
All right,
so you look,
look at game one and fill out that form for me.
Okay.
So while you're filling that out,
let me tell you a little bit about what we're going to be doing here.
So what is game theory?
Game Theory is a method of studying strategic situations.
Okay,
so what's a strategic situation?
Well,
let's start off with what's not as strategic strategic situation in your
economics,
your intro economics class and one 15 or one 10 you saw some pretty good
examples of situations that were not strategic.
You saw firms working in perfect competition,
right?
Firms in perfect competition are price taker.
They don't particularly have to worry about the actions of their competitors,
right?
You also firms that will monopolists and monopolies don't have any competitors
to worry about.
So that's not a particular strategic situation.
They're not price takers,
but they take the demand curve,
right?
Is this looking familiar for some of you who can remember doing one 15 last year
or maybe two years ago?
For some of you?
All right.
Everything in between is strategic.
So everything that constitutes in perfect competition is,
is a strategic setting.
Think about the motor industry,
the motorcar industry.
Ford has to worry about what GM is doing and what Toyota is doing.
And but for the moment at least what Christ was doing with perhaps not for long.
All right?
All right.
So there's a small number of firms that actions affect each other.
All right,
so for literal definition of what strategic means,
it's a setting where the outcomes that that affect you depend on actions,
not just on your own actions but on actions of others.
All right.
As much as I'm going to say for preview right now,
we're going to come back and see plenty of this over the course of the next
semester.
So what I want to do is get on it to where we are,
where the supplies are.
Obviously it applies in economics but it also applies in politics and in fact
this class will count as a political science class if you're a political science
majors are going to check with the Dus in political science,
right?
It counted game theory is very important in law these days,
so for those of you for the half of you are going to end up in law school.
This is pretty good training.
Game Theory is also used in biology and towards the middle of the semester we're
actually going to see some examples of game theory as applied to evolution.
And Not surprisingly,
game theory is a applies to sport.
All right,
so let's talk a little bit of Admin.
How are you doing on a filling out those games?
Everyone mount mentioned to multitask.
Again,
game one,
keep racing.
I want to get some admin out of the way and I want to start by getting out of
the way.
What is obviously the elephant in the room.
And some of you will have noticed that there's a camera crew here.
Okay.
So I,
as some of you probably know,
a Yale is undergoing a,
an open education project and they're videoing several clauses.
And the idea of this is to make educational materials available beyond the walls
of Yale.
In fact,
on the web internationally.
So people in places,
maybe places in the u s or places miles away,
maybe in,
in,
in Timbuktu or whatever,
who had it difficult to get educational materials,
uh,
from a local university or whatever can watch certain lectures from Yale.
On the web.
All right.
Some of you would have been in classes that do that before.
What's going to be different about this class is that you're going to be
participating in it,
right?
The way we teach this class is going to play games.
We're going to have discussions,
we're going to talk among among the class,
and you're going to be learning from each other,
right?
And I want you to help people watching at home to be able to learn too.
And that means you're going to be on film at very least on Mike.
All right?
So how's that gonna work around the room are three TA's holding Mike's,
I mean show you where they are.
One here,
one here and one here.
When I asked for classroom discussions,
I'm going to have one of the TA's go to you with a microphone.
Uh,
much like in know Donahue or something.
Okay?
All right?
And at certain times you're going to be seen on film,
so the camera is actually going to come around and point in your direction.
Now I really want this to happen.
I had to argue for this to happen because I really feel that this class isn't
about me.
I'm,
you know,
I'm part of the clause obviously,
but it's about you teaching each other and and participating.
Right?
But there's a catch.
The catch is that that means you have to sign that legal release form.
So you'll see that you have in front of you a legal release form.
You have to assign it.
And what that says is that we can use you being shown in class.
Think of this as a bad hair day release form,
right?
You can't sue Yale later if you had a bad hair day.
Right?
For those of you who are on the run from the FBI,
your visa's run out or you're sitting next to your ex girlfriend,
now would be a good time to put a paper bag over your head.
All right.
Now just to get used to the idea a,
in every class we're going to have a,
I think the same two people.
So Judas,
the camera man,
when you all wave to do this is to wait.
Yeah,
right,
right.
Okay.
And where is our audio guy?
This is where it is.
Right?
And I will try to remember not to include June ways in the classroom
discussions,
but you should be aware that they're there.
All right.
Is this is making you nervous?
If it's any consolation,
it's making me very nervous.
Okay.
So all right.
We'll try and make this class work as smoothly as we can,
allowing for this extra thing.
And let me say,
no one's making any money off this bitch.
I'm hoping these guys are being paid,
but me and the TA's are not being paid.
This is the aim of this is I think as a good aim.
It's an educational project and I'm hoping you'll help us with it.
All right.
The one difference is,
is going to mean is that at times I might hold some of the discussions for the
class coming down into this part of the,
uh,
of the,
of the room here to make it a little easier,
uh,
for Jude.
All right.
How are we doing now and filling out this form?
Does everyone filled in their strategy for the first game?
Not yet.
Okay.
So let's go and doing a bit more admin.
The thing you mostly of Caravan I'm guessing is the grades.
All right,
so how has the gray you're going to work for this plus 30% of the class will be
on problem sets that didn't have the grade 30% on the midterm and 40% on the
final,
so 30 30 40 the mid term will be held in class on October 17 that is also on
your syllabus.
Doughnut.
Please don't anybody tell me late.
You know anytime after today you didn't know when the midterm wasn't there.
Your for you,
it clashes with 17 different things.
The mid term is on October 17th is a Wednesday in class.
All right.
The problem sets,
there will be a roughly 10 problems sets and I'll talk about them more later on
when I hand them out.
The first one,
we'll go out on Monday,
but it'll do a 10 days later.
Roughly speaking,
there'll be every week the grade distribution.
All right,
so this is the rough grade division.
Roughly speaking,
a sick that the class are going to end up with A's.
A stick is going to end up with a minus a stick cause they gonna end up with B
plus a take is gonna end up with be a sticker again,
not with B minus and the remaining sick.
If I added that up right,
I'm going to end up with what I guess we're now calling the presidential great.
Is that right?
That's not literally true.
I'm going to squeeze it a bit.
I'm going to cover it.
A bed.
So actually a slightly fewer Vanna sixth,
we'll get straight A's and fewer than a six.
We'll get uh,
you know,
seasoned below.
We'll squeeze the middle to make the,
make them be more bees.
Uh,
one thing I can guarantee you from past experience in this class is that the
median grade will be a B plus at the median.
We'll hit fall somewhere in the B pluses.
All right.
Now just as for wanting for people who forgotten what a median is,
that means half of you,
not,
not approximately half.
It means exactly half of you will be getting something like B plus and below and
a half.
We think something might be passing the off.
Okay.
Now how are you doing and filling in the forms.
Everyone filled it in yet.
Surely must be pretty close to getting up on Phil then.
All right,
so,
uh,
last things to talk about before you actually collect them in textbooks that are
textbooks for this class,
the main textbook is this one doctor's book,
strategy and Games.
If you want a slightly tougher book,
more rigorous book,
Try Joel Watson's book strategies.
Both of those books are available at the bookstore.
All right,
but I want to warn everybody ahead of time.
I will not be following the textbook.
I regard these books as safety nets.
If you don't understand something that happened in class,
you want to reinforce an idea that came up in class,
then you should read the relevant chapters in the book and the syllabus will
tell you which chapters to read for each class or each week in the class,
right?
But I will win.
I will not be following these books religiously at all.
In fact,
that just there as backup.
In addition,
I strongly recommend people read thinking strategically.
This is a good bedtime reading to any stuff from insomnia.
It's very good bedtime reading and his upper ms on it.
This it's a good book.
And what's more,
there's going to be a new edition of this book this year and northern have
allowed us to get advanced copies of it.
So if you don't buy this book this week,
I may be able to make the advanced copy of the new edition available for some of
you next week.
And I'm not taking a cut of that either,
right there,
isn't it?
There's no money changing hands then.
Alright,
sections on the syllabus signup.
Oh sorry.
On the website.
Sign up as usual.
Put yourself down on the wait list.
If you don't get to the section you want,
you probably will get into the section.
You won't once we're done.
All right,
now in must be done with the forms we've done with the forms.
so why don't we send the TA's with or without Mike's up and down the aisles and
collected your game.
Number one,
not,
not getting number two,
just game number one.
Just when we're doing that.
I think the reputation of this class,
I think if you look at the cost evaluations online or whatever,
is that this class is reasonably hard but reasonably fun.
Alright,
so I,
I'm hoping that's what rotation in the plastic is.
All right.
So you shouldn't,
if you think this course is gonna be,
is gonna be easy?
I think it isn't actually an easy class.
It's actually got a card class,
but I think I can guarantee it's going to be a fun class.
Now,
one reason it's a fun class is the Nice thing about teaching Game Theory,
quieting down folks,
when I think that teaching game theory is you get to play games and that's
exactly what we've just been doing now.
This is our first game and we're going to play games throughout the course
sometimes several times a week,
sometimes just once a week.
We've got all these things then everyone handed the men,
right?
So I need to get those counted.
Has anyone taken the Yale accounting tasks?
No one wants to.
No one has aspirations to at one person has.
I'll have a ta dude.
It's all right.
Levitated so w,
uh,
Kai,
can you count those for me?
Is that right?
Let me read out the game you've just played.
Game One,
a simple grade scheme for the class.
Read the following carefully without showing your neighbor what you're doing.
Put it in the box below either the letter alpha,
all the latter.
Bita,
think of this as a great bid.
I will randomly pair your phone with another form and neither you nor your power
will ever know with whom you are pad.
Here's how the grades may be assigned for the class or they won't be what we can
pretend.
If you put Alpha and your [inaudible] Bita,
then you will get an a and your pants or see if you and your pad both but Alpha,
you're both get B minus.
If you put bita and no parents Alpha,
you'll get a c in your parent at an a.
And if you interrupt pat both put pizza,
then you'll both get B plus.
All right,
so that's the thing you just filled in.
Now before we talk about this,
let's just collect this information in a more useful ways.
I'm going to remove this for now.
Okay.
All right.
We'll discuss this in a second,
but why don't we actually record what the game is that we're playing first.
Okay,
so this is our grade gain and what am I going to do?
Since it's kind of hard to absorb all the information by reading a paragraph of
text,
I'm going to make a table to record the information.
Okay?
So I'm gonna do is I'm going to put me here and my path,
the person I'm randomly paired with yet,
and Alpha and Beta,
which are the choices I'm going to make here and on the columns,
Alpha and Beta,
the choices my parents making.
And in this table I'm going to put my grades.
All right?
So my grades,
if I,
if we both put alpha is B minus,
if we both put Bitsa was B plus,
if I put Alpha and she put a Beazer,
I got an a and if I put beets are and she put an Alpha,
I got to see,
is that correct?
That's more or less,
right.
Okay.
While we're here,
why don't we do the same for my path?
Brian,
so this is my grades and the left hand table,
but now
let's look at what my panel of date,
all my power gap.
Okay,
so I should warn people sitting at the bank that my handwriting is pretty bad.
That's one reason for moving forward.
The other thing I should apologize for this state at this stage of the class is
my accent.
I will try and improve the handwriting.
There's not much I can do about the accident at this stage.
All right,
so once again,
if we both put alpha,
that may pair gets a B minus and we both put Bita,
then we both get a B plus it kind of pat gets a B.
Plus.
If I put Alpha and my path puts bita,
then she gets a c and if I put Bita and she puts alpha,
then she gets an a,
right?
It's why not have all the information that was on the sheet of paper that you
just handed in.
All right.
Now there's another way of organizing this,
that standard in Game Theory,
so we might as well get used to it now on the first day,
rather than drawing two different tables like this,
what I'm gonna do is I'm going to take the second table and super impose it on
top of the first people.
Okay,
so let me do that and you'll see what I mean.
Am I'm going to do is draw a larger table.
The same basic structure.
I'm choosing Alpha and Beta on the rose.
My pair is choosing Alpha and Beta on the columns,
but now I'm going to put both grades in.
So the easy ones on the diagonal,
you both get B minus.
If we both choose Alpha,
we both get B plus if we both choose beats at all,
right?
But if I choose Alpha on my patch,
she his pizza,
I get an a and she gets a c and if I choose pizza and she chooses Alpha,
then it's me.
You get to the sea and it's her who gets Yay.
All right,
so is what I did here.
The first grade corresponds to the row player me in this case,
how am the second grade?
Each box corresponds to the column player.
My pair in this case.
So this is a nice six things way of recording what was in the previous two
tables.
All right.
And this is an outcome matrix.
This tells us everything that was in the game.
It's an outcome matrix.
All right?
Okay.
So now it seems a good time to start talking about what people did.
So,
uh,
let's just have a show of hands.
How many of you uh,
chose Alpha?
Leave your hands up so that you can catch that.
So just two people can see at home.
Okay.
All right.
And how many of you shows Bita Nice,
far more out in a day?
Can they be wave your hands to be?
It is.
Okay.
All right.
There's a to here.
Okay.
So it looks like a lot of,
well,
we're going to find out.
We're going to count,
but a lot more alphas and Betas.
Let me try and find out some reasons why people chose.
Let me have the Alphas up again.
Uh,
so,
uh,
the,
the woman who's in red here,
can we get a mic to the,
yeah.
Okay.
We asked you are you,
you're not on the run from the FBI.
We can ask you why,
why?
Okay.
So you just alpha,
right?
So why did you choose alpha?
Okay.
Oh,
are you,
so,
so you wrote out these squares,
you realize that your partner was going to do and responded to that.
And the other reasons for choosing Alpha around the room to take,
we can,
can we get the,
the,
the woman in here?
I don't to be intimidated by these microphones that just Mike's,
yeah,
regardless of what my partner chose,
I think there'd be better outcomes
since using.
All right,
so,
so let me ask you to names the second.
So your name was Courtney and your name was clarity's.
So slightly different reasons.
Same choice.
Alpha Clara,
Lisa's reason.
But apparently you stay,
she said,
no matter what the other person does,
she reckon she'd get to get a better grade if she chose Alpha.
So hold that thought a second.
We'll come back to,
is it Clairol?
Clairol East,
is that right?
I'll come back to clarity in a second.
Let's talk to the beat as a second.
Let me just emphasize at this stage,
there are no wrong answers.
Later on in the class,
they'll become questions would have wrong answers.
Right now there's no wrong answers.
All right.
There may be bad reasons,
but there's no wrong answers.
So that's of the beat is up again.
Let's,
let's do the bts.
Oh,
come on.
It was a be the right here.
You were beaten,
right?
You've backed off the beater.
Okay.
Uh,
so how can I get a mic into a pizza?
Is that sticking this isle a bit?
Is that a pizza right there you are.
You'd be the right.
That was a can.
Can I get the,
are in here?
Who the beat in here?
Can we get,
can we get the mic in there?
That possible in here?
He can leave your hand up.
So yeah,
we go.
Let me go.
Just point towards,
that's fine.
That's fine.
Just,
just,
just to speak into it.
That's fine.
Yeah,
go ahead.
I personally don't like swings that much and it's the beamline is fee plus
range.
So I'd much rather prefer that to a swing from a to c.
Oh,
that's right.
So you're saying you're saying it compresses the writing?
I'm not sure it does compress the right ended.
I mean,
I mean if you shows a Alpha,
uh,
you're,
you're swinging from a to B minus of bring from BDO treason from B pass to see.
I mean there's a similar kind of ranges,
but it's,
it's certainly reasons,
other reasons for choosing.
Yeah.
The guy in blue it here.
Yup.
Yeah.
Good.
That's,
I just don't,
don't hold the mic.
Just let the point.
Well,
I guess I thought we could be more collusive and kind of work together,
but I guess not.
Um,
so,
uh,
I chose Beta is that just shows me back on,
I missed the answer is to stand up just here.
Yep.
Sorry,
say it again.
Sure.
My name is Travis.
Uh,
I thought we could work together,
but I guess not.
All right.
All right,
good.
Good.
If you had chosen bed and we would all look pretty good buses,
but it's not,
okay.
So,
so Travis,
he's giving us a different reason,
right?
He's saying he's saying that maybe,
maybe some of you in the room might actually care about each other's grades,
right?
I mean,
you all know each other in class,
you will go to the same college.
For example,
if we,
uh,
if we played this game,
up in,
uh,
up in the business school MBA students here today want to say,
right?
We were,
we played this game up on the business school.
I think it's quite lately we're going to get a lot of Alphas chosen,
right?
But if we played this game up in that,
say,
the divinity school,
all right.
Guessing that.
I'm guessing that Travis,
his answer is reflecting what you guys are running it.
If you played in the divinity school,
you might think that people in divinity school might care about other people's
grades,
right?
There might be ethical reasons,
perfectly good,
sensible ethical reasons for choosing Peter in this game.
Might be other reasons as well.
But that's,
that's the reason to focus on and perhaps the,
the lesson I want to draw out of this is that right now,
this is not a game right now.
We have action strategists we want to take and we know what the outcomes are,
but we're missing something that will make this,
again,
what are we missing here?
We're missing objectives were missing.
Payoffs are missing what people care about.
All right?
So we can't really start analyzing a game until we know what people care about.
And do we know what the payoffs are?
And let's,
let's just say something now,
which I'll probably forget to say it any other,
any other moments of the class,
but today it's relevant,
right?
Game Theory me professors at Yale cannot tell you what your payoff should be.
They should not care.
We can't,
I can't tell you in a useful what it is that you should meet your goals in life
should be or whatever,
right?
That's not what came through is the powers.
However,
once we know what your pay payoffs I want,
we know what your goals are,
perhaps we can gain three can help you get there.
All right,
so we've had two different kinds of payoffs mentioned here.
We had the kind of payoff where we care about our own grade and Travis has
mentioned the kind of pay off when you might care about other people's grades.
And what we're gonna do today is ally as this game under both those possible
payoffs.
Just start that off.
Let's put up some possible payoffs for the game.
Okay?
And I promise we'll come back and look at some other pay off later.
We'll,
we'll,
we'll revisit the divinity school later.
All right,
so here,
once again is our same matrix with me in my path choosing actions,
Alpha and Beta.
But this time I'm going to put numbers in here
and some of you will recognize these numbers,
but that's not really relevant for now.
All right,
so what's the idea here with the first idea is that these numbers represent you,
tiles or utilities that they represent.
What this,
what these people are trying to maximize what they're trying to achieve that
goals.
All right.
Did,
the idea is to just be,
just compare this to the outcome matrix is for the person who's me here.
Ac yields a pay off.
Uh,
it's an HD has this box.
So AC yields a payoff of three,
whereas B minus B minus,
yeah.
Eels a payoff of zero and so on.
All right.
So what's the interpretation is the first interpretation,
which the knack for interpretation that a lot of you jumped to straight away.
These are people,
people with these payoffs are people who only care about their own grades.
They prefer an a to a B.
Plus they prefer a B plus two B minus,
and they'd put a B minus to a c.
Right.
I'm happy about that.
All the grades in order,
otherwise it's going to ruin my curve at the end of the year.
All right.
So these people only care about their own grades.
I only care
about that owner.
Great.
What do we call people who only care about their own grades?
What's a good technical term for them?
Awesome.
In England,
I think we refer to these guys,
those technical or not as an evil gates,
how many these are not,
you're not perhaps the most moral people in the universe.
All right,
so now we're gonna ask a different question.
Suppose whether he's actually a powerful and not pretend they are for now.
All right.
Suppose he's your payoffs.
Now we can ask not what did you do,
but what should you do?
Now we have payoffs that can really switch the question to a naughty question.
What should you do?
And let's come back to,
uh,
to it,
a Clara lease.
What was parolees before?
And let's get the mic on you again.
So just explain what you did and why.
Again,
why chose Alpha?
Yes,
I'm setting up a second.
Okay.
That's okay.
All right.
Usually you shoot al fine.
I'm just doing this.
But roughly your payoff more or less,
right?
You were caring about your grades.
Yeah.
Why did they choose alpha?
I'm sorry.
Why did you choose often?
Just repeat what you said before.
Because I thought the paps,
the two different paths that I could have gotten were highest.
If I chose Alpha.
Good.
So what clarity is,
is saying it's important idea is the,
isn't it?
Tell me if I'm paraphrasing you incorrectly,
but I think this is more or less what you're saying is no matter what the other
person does,
no matter what the pair does,
she obtains a higher payoff by choosing Alpha.
Lets us see that if the pair of shoes is Alpha and uh,
she chooses Alpha,
then she gets zero.
If the pat chooses Alpha and she chose Bita,
she gets minus one.
Zero is bigger than minus one.
All right?
If the pair of shoes is Beta and if she chooses alpha,
she gets three meters,
she gets one and three is bigger than one.
So in both cases,
no matter what the other person does,
she receives a higher payoff from choosing Alpha.
So she should choose alpha.
Why does everyone follow that roadmap,
that line of reasoning?
That's a stronger line of reasoning.
The reasoning we had earlier so that I won't,
I've never immediately forgotten the name of in the red shirt,
uh,
whose name was Courtney.
Courtney also gave a reason for choosing Alpha.
And there was a perfectly good reason for the alpha.
Nothing wrong with it,
but notice that this reasons that a stronger isn't,
it kind of implies your reason.
All right.
All right,
so let's get some definitions down here.
Okay.
I think I can fit it in here.
Let's try and fit it in here.
Definition
we say
that my strategy
I'll fuck strictly dominates.
Yeah,
strictly dominates.
Okay.
My strategy be side
if my pay off
from alpha.
Okay.
Is strictly
great,
sir.
Van Vat
from visa and this is the key part of the definition regardless
of what others
do,
of what others do.
Just read that back.
We stayed the,
my strategy Alpha strictly dominates my strategy be set.
If my payoff from Alpha is strictly greater than that from Bita,
regardless of what others do.
Now it's by no means might main aim in this class to teach you target.
All right,
but a few bits of jargon I'm going to be helpful in in allowing the conversation
to move forward and this is certainly one evil gets is maybe one too,
but this is certainly one.
All right,
let's draw some lessons from this and actually sweet.
So you can still read that and you bring it down and clean this board.
Yeah.
So the first lesson of the class and this to be lots of lessons,
there's a lesson that emerges is immediately from the definition of a dominant,
all of a domination strategy.
And it's this.
So less than one of the course is do not play
a strictly
dominated
strategy.
All right?
So with apologist,
a strong can wait.
This is the passive form.
Okay.
There's Dominique,
ted passive voice.
Do not play a strictly dominated
strategy.
Why?
Want to tell me why?
Yeah,
I'll going to get this guy.
yeah.
Stand up.
Yep is right.
Yes.
Yup.
You guys.
Everyone's going to pick this,
the dominant outcome and then everyone's going to get the worst result.
The collectively work.
Hello.
Shut up.
That's a possible answer.
I'm looking for something more direct here.
So w we,
we looked at the definition of strictly domination strategy.
I'm saying never play one.
What's a possible reason for that?
Let's,
let's,
uh,
can we get the,
the woman there,
you always lose.
While I know this isn't about winning and losing.
What else can we have?
Can we get this,
this guy in the pink down here?
Yeah,
well the payoffs Haloa the payoffs are lower.
Okay,
so,
so here's a,
here's an abbreviated version of that and that's perhaps a little bit,
it's not supported previous tables not long ago.
The reason I don't want to play a strictly dominated strategy is by if instead I
play the strategy that dominates it.
I do better on every case.
All right.
The reason I never wanted to play a strictly dominate Ted strategy is if instead
they pay the strategy that dominates it.
Whatever anyone else does,
I'm doing better than I would've done.
All right,
well that's a pretty convincing argument.
That sounds like a convincing arguments.
It sounds like too obvious even to worth be worth stating in class.
All right,
so let me now try and shake your faith a little bit in this,
in this answer.
All right.
Somebody who's wanted by the FBI,
right.
Okay.
So,
okay,
how about the following argument?
Look at the payoff matrix again.
And I suppose I reasoned this follows.
Suppose I reasoned and say,
if we,
me and my pack both reason this way and choose alpha,
then we'll both get zero.
But if we both reasoned a different way and shows Beta,
then we'll both get one.
So I should choose B to one's bigger than zero.
I should choose Peta.
What's wrong with that argument?
Malaga must be wrong because it goes against the lesson or the class and the
lesson for the class.
The Gospel,
right.
They're not wrong ever.
So what's wrong with that argument?
What's wrong with that argument?
Yeah,
yeah.
That's good.
Just,
just,
yeah,
yeah.
Good.
Well,
because you have to be able to agree.
You have to go to speak to them,
but we aren't allowed to show our partners what we wrote.
All right.
So it involves some notion of agreeing in Baltimore notion of grieving.
So certainly part of the problem here with the reasoning,
I just gave you the reasoning that said I should choose Bita because if we both
reason the same way we both do better that way involves some kind of magical
reasoning.
It's as if I'm arguing that if I reasoned this way and reason myself to choose
and pizza somehow,
I'm going to make the rest of you reasoned the same way too.
It's like I've got ESP or I'm some character out of a,
uh,
do you hold the x men?
Is that what it's called?
The ECZEMA?
Right.
Right now,
in fact,
it's become a surprise to you.
I'm not,
I don't have ESPN,
not a character out of the expanded.
So you can't actually see brain waves emanating from my head and my reasoning
doesn't affect your reasoning.
Right?
So if I did reason that way and chose Beta,
I'm not going to affect your choice one way or the other.
Why doesn't the first thing that's wrong with that reasoning,
what else is wrong with that reasoning?
Yeah,
that guy down here.
Yeah.
Well,
the second that you choose B to then someone's going,
it's in someone's best interest to take advantage of you all right.
Just wasn't taken devotion me.
But even more than that even stronger organ though.
That's true.
But even a strong growing it.
Well,
how about this?
Even if I could,
even if I was that guy in the x men or the Matrix or whoever it was who could
reason his way into making people do things.
Even if I could make everyone in the room,
she was [inaudible] by the force of my brainwaves.
What should I then do?
I should choose alpha.
These are my pay offs.
I should go ahead and choose alpha cause I that way I ended up getting three.
All right,
so it's,
there's two things wrong with the argument.
One does this magical reasoning aspect.
My reasoning is controlling your actions.
That doesn't happen in the real world and to even if that was the case,
I do better to myself.
Choose out.
All right,
so
nevertheless,
there's an element of truth and what I just say that it's the fact there's an
element of truth in it that makes it very,
you know,
it seems like a good,
a good argument.
The element of truth is this.
It is true that by both choosing Alpha,
we both ended up with B minuses.
We both it with payoffs of zero rather than pay offs of one.
It is true that by both choosing,
by both following this lesson and not choosing the dominated strategy
[inaudible] we ended up with zero.
Zero that were bad.
All right?
That's probably the second lesson of the class.
So less than two
I'm just guessing,
probably wouldn't with spacing.
And it wasn't the first third of a century of thought in economics that said the
opposite.
So rational choice,
in this case,
people not choosing a dominated strategy,
people choosing a dominant strategy.
Rational choice can lead to outcomes that what Americans call lists.
Let's talk.
All right?
If you want a more technical term for that,
and you remember this from echo from economics one 15 can lead to the outcome
for the inefficiencies that Burrito and efficient,
but the sock we'll do for today,
right?
Rational choice by rational players can lead to bad outcomes.
Okay,
so this is a famous example for this reason.
It's a good illustration of this point.
It's a famous example.
What's the name of this example?
Somebody.
This is called prisoner's dilemma.
How many of you have heard of the prisoner's dilemma before?
They must use 2115 why is it called the prisoner's dilemma?
Yeah,
so the guy here in orange,
that's okay.
Let's just do it.
You can just point to you.
That's fine.
I think it's whether or not the prisoners cooperate in the sentence they have
and if the kind of read out the other person and they could have less bright red
out,
then Dave like ended up losing large scale.
Good,
good turn.
The Standard story you've got these two crooks are two accused crux and they're
in separate cells and they're being interviewed separately,
kept apart and they're both told that if neither of them routes the other guy
out,
they'll go to jail for to say a year.
If they both write each other out,
they'll end up in jail for two years.
But if you wrap the other guy out and he doesn't write you out,
then you will go home free and he'll go to jail for five years and you put that
all down.
You're pretty quickly see that regardless where the other guy rats you out or
not,
you're better off ratting him out.
All right.
Now,
if you haven't ever seen that prisoner's dilemma,
you can see it,
uh,
pretty much every night,
on a show called Lauren order.
How many of you have seen Lauren order?
All right.
If you haven't seen Lauren Oda,
the way to see Lauren order is to go to a random TV sets at a random time and
turn of a random channel.
There's,
this happens in every single episode.
So much so that if any of you actually,
I mean,
this might not be true at yeah.
If any of you or the TV guys,
if any of you know the guy who writes the plots for this,
have him come to the class,
I guess,
see the video now and we can get some better plot lines in there,
right?
All right.
But of course,
that's not the only example.
The grade game.
And this is not the only example.
There are lots of examples of prisoner's dilemma is out there.
Let's try and find some other ones.
All right.
So how many of you have roommates in your,
in your college?
Let me go roommates.
Most of you have roommates,
right?
Right.
So,
uh,
I'm now,
but I won't make you show your hands cause it's pretty embarrassing.
But what is the state of your dorm rooms,
your shared dorm rooms at the end of the semester or the end of the school year?
All right,
so I'm just guessing,
I haven't been in a few of these things over the years that by the end of the
semester,
I said by the end of the school year,
the state of the average Yale Dorm Room is quite disgusting.
All right.
Why is this?
Why is it disgusting?
It's disgusting cause people don't tidy up right then and clean out those bits
of pizza and bits of chewed bread and she eats.
But why don't they tidy up?
What is just work it out.
What would you like to happen if you're sharing a dorm room,
you'd like to have the other guy tidy up,
right?
Right.
The best thing for you is to have the other k tidy up and the worst thing for
you is to tidy up for the other guy.
But now work it out.
It's a prisoner's dilemma.
If the other guy doesn't tidy up,
you're best off not turning up either cause the last thing you want is to be
tightening up the other guy.
And if the other guy does tidy up,
hey,
the rooms clean,
who cares?
Either way you're not going to tidy up and you end up with a typical Yale Room.
Am I being in or your dorm room is all perfect.
This may be agenda thing,
but we're not going to go there.
All right.
So there are lots of prisoner's dilemma is out there and I'm gonna get out.
Any other examples?
Other examples?
I didn't quite hear that.
Sorry.
It's trying to get a mic on it.
You can really hear it
paying up and a lot of money,
Huh?
Okay.
And divorce and divorce struggles.
That's okay.
You're too young to worry about such things,
but never mind.
Never mind.
Yeah.
Okay.
That's a good example cause all right.
Hiring lawyers,
link getting,
bring in big guns.
What about in economics example
at firms who are competing in prices,
right.
Both firms have an incentive to undercut the other firm driving down profits for
both.
Right?
The last thing you want to have the other firm undercut you and they're going to
push prices down.
That's good for us to consumers,
but bad for the firm pad industry profit.
What remedies do we see?
We will,
we'll come back to this later on in the class,
but let's have a preview.
So what remedies do we see in society for prisoners?
Dilemmas?
What kind of remedies we see?
Let me try and get,
uh,
get the guy here and he's right in front in front of your collusion,
collusion,
collusion.
Okay.
So firms could collude.
All right.
So,
uh,
what,
what prevents them from colluding prevention,
including one thing they could do?
Presumably if they could write a contract,
these firms,
they could say,
I won't lower my prices if you don't lower your prices.
And they could put this contract in with the precis lawyer who's taking a day
off from the divorce court and that will secure that.
They wouldn't say lower prices on each other.
Is that right?
All right.
So why wouldn't that work?
Why wouldn't writing a contract here work?
Right?
It's against the law,
right?
Legal contract.
It's an illegal contract.
All right.
What about you with your roommates?
How many of you have a written contract?
No stuck with a magnet on the fridge telling you you're posting when you're
supposed to tidy up.
Very few of you,
right?
Why?
Why do you manage to get some cooperation between you and your roommates?
Even without us,
even without a written contract,
not legally.
Well,
I'd probably is legally enforceable.
Actually.
This guys,
it's not even pretty easily enforceable.
You probably could have a written contract about tidying up.
Yeah.
The,
the,
the woman in the,
in here yet repetition.
You do it over and over.
Yeah,
so maybe,
maybe even among your roommates,
maybe you don't need a contract because you can manage to achieve the same ends
by the fact that you're going to be interacting with the same person over and
over again during your time at Yale.
So we'll come back and revisit the idea that repeating an interaction may be may
allow you to attain cooperation,
but we're not going to come back to that till after the midterm.
That's way down the road.
But we'll get there.
All right.
Now,
one person earlier on had mentioned something about communication.
I think it was only the front,
right?
So that's the thing about this.
The second is communication.
The problem here is that it's the reason people behave badly in this l babby
people choose Alpha in this game here.
Is it the fact that they can't communicate?
That's where I suppose you could,
I suppose you'd be able to talk beforehand as oppose.
The woman whose name was Mary,
had been to talk to the person next door,
who's name is Erica,
and they'd said,
you know,
supposedly were going to be paired together.
I'll choose beater,
a few shoes,
pizza without work.
Why wouldn't that work?
Yep.
There's no enforcement.
Right?
So it isn't a failure of communication per se,
right?
A contract is more than communication.
A contracts is communication with teeth,
right?
It actually changes the payoffs.
So I could communicate with allies,
I'm agreements,
but back home,
I'm going to go and go ahead and choose Alpha anyway,
all the better if he's choosing Peter.
All right.
So we'll come back and talk about more of these things as the course goes on.
But I've just come back to the two.
We forgot that.
So the collusion case and the case back in law and order with the,
with the prisoners and the salary,
how do they enforce that contract?
So when they do it,
always rat each other's out and some of manage managed to collude.
How do they manage to enforce those contracts?
There was agreement.
How are they enforced?
Yep.
The Cooper,
they trust each other that well.
If you trust a crook,
that's not,
yeah.
What,
what else could it be?
And the guy,
the guy here again,
the big yeah.
Is your sum game.
Well,
but this is the game,
right?
So here's the games.
We'll come a little bit to pet the way they value.
All right,
good.
Good.
The payoffs may be different.
A different,
I have something simpler in mind.
How it's,
suppose they have a written contract or even an unwritten contract.
What enforces the contract for colluding firms or crux in jail?
Yep.
Free and five years when the other guy gets out,
he might run into a situation.
Yeah,
so a short version of that is it's a different kind of contract.
If you rat someone out in jail,
someone puts a contract out on you.
All right.
Tony Soprano enforces those contracts.
That's the purpose of Tony Soprano is the purpose of the map.
Yet the reason the mafia thrives in countries where it's hard to write legal
contracts at say some new,
some new parts of the former Soviet Union or some parts of Africa.
The reason the mafia thrives in those environments is that it substitutes for
the law and enforces both legal and illegal contracts.
All right,
so I promised a while ago now that we were going to come back and look at this
game under some other possible payoffs,
so let,
no,
I was under a contract,
but let's come back and fulfill that promise anyway,
so we're going to revisit,
if not the divinity school,
at least in people who have more morality than my friends up in the business
school.
We're going to ask for the same grade game we played at the,
at the beginning.
What would happen if players' payoffs look different?
Yeah,
so these are possible payoffs to all right.
And I'll give these a name.
We called the other guy's evil gates.
So we'll get,
we'll call these guys indignant angels.
I can never spell indignant.
Is that roughly right?
But look right.
I think it's right.
The ligament,
isn't it indignant?
Alright.
Indignant angels.
We'll see why in a second.
So here are their payoffs.
And once again,
the basic structure,
the game hasn't changed.
It's still I'm choosing Alfin pizza.
My Paris choosing our firm be set and the grades are the same as they were
before.
They're hidden by that board.
But you saw them before.
All right,
but this time the payoffs are as follows.
On the lead diagonal,
we still have zero,
zero and one one but now the grades here,
a minus one and Mike at the pay offs are minus one and minus three on here.
Then minus three and minus one.
I watched the idea here is on the only other possible pals is just an idea.
Suppose I get an a and my pad gets a c,
then sure I get that initial payoff of three.
But unfortunately I can't sleep at night and I'm feeling so guilty.
Right?
I have some,
I have some kind of moral conscience and after I subtracted off my guilt
feelings,
I ended up at minus one.
So think of this as guilt,
some notion of morality.
Alright,
how conversely,
if I chose a beach or my patches an Alpha,
so I end up with a c and she ends up with an a,
then you know,
I have a bad time explaining to my parents where I got a c in this class and I
have to say about how I'm going to be president anyway.
But then in addition,
I feel indignation against this person.
It isn't just that I got to see,
I got to see because she made me get a see.
All right,
so that moral indignation takes us down to minus three.
Yeah.
All right.
So again,
I'm not,
I'm not claiming these are the only other possible payoffs,
but just another possible look at,
okay,
so I suppose these were the payoffs in the game.
Might again,
suspend disbelief for a second and imagine that these actually are your payoffs.
And let me ask you what you would have done in this case.
Think about it a second,
right?
And write it down.
Write down what you're going to do on the corner of your notepad.
Just write down at Al for ob.
So what you're going to do here,
and not all writing the guy in the Indian shed hasn't,
right?
You've gotta be writing group in England yet?
Sure it's your neighbor
that's have a show of hands.
Again,
I want to keep,
keep your hands up so that a Jew can see it now.
So how many of you chose Alpha in this case?
Raise your hands.
Going to be shy.
How many of beads or in this case,
how many people abstained,
not allowed to have saying,
let's try it again.
Alpha Alpha in this case,
no extensions here.
Beat her in this case.
So we'll roughly split in the room.
Often Room.
Someone who chose Alpha again,
rose the Alphas again.
All right everybody get this guy here.
Uh,
ally,
can we get this guy here?
So what,
why did you choose alpha?
Uh,
you minimize your losses.
You'd get zero or negative one instead of negative three or one.
All right,
so,
so this gentleman saying strategy.
So reits are the,
did this disturbance saying a good reason for choosing how for this game is it's
less risky,
right?
The worst case scenario is less bad.
And again,
all right,
what about somebody who should speed a lot of your shows?
Peter [inaudible].
Show of hands on the beaches again.
Let me see the Beatles again.
So,
uh,
again,
raise your hands,
raise your hands.
Can we get,
can we get the woman here?
Can we ask her why she chose Peter?
Um,
because if you choose Alpha,
the best case scenarios,
you get zero.
Good.
That's a good counter argument.
So the gentleman here was looking at the worst case scenario and the woman here
was to get the best case scenario.
The best case scenario here.
Looks like,
uh,
getting a one here.
All right.
Now that's also a different question.
Is one of the strategies dominated in this game?
No.
Neither strategist dominated.
It's just check if my pair choose is Alpha than my choosing Alpha yield zero
bita minus three.
So alpha would be better,
but if my patches is bita than Alpha yields minus one pizza yields one,
in this case,
Peter would be better.
All right,
so I'll throw in this case it's better against Alpha and Beta has got a better
against pizza,
but neither dominate each other.
Alright,
so here's a game where it's,
we just changed the pay off.
We have the same basic structure,
the same outcomes,
but we're managing people cared about different things or we end up with a very
different answer.
In the first game,
it was kind of clear that we should choose alpha and here it's not a tall,
clear what we can do,
what we should do,
right?
In fact,
this kind of game has a name and we'll revisit it later on this semester.
This kind of game is called a coordination problem.
Well,
we'll talk about coordination problems later on,
but the main lesson I want to get out of this,
but today is the simplest.
It's the lesson that payoffs matter.
All right?
We changed the payoffs,
we change what people cared about and we get a very different game with a very
different outcome.
All right?
So there's a,
the basic lesson is
the payoff's matter,
but let me say it a different way.
So without giving away my age too much,
well guess we'll actually,
when I was a kid growing up in England,
there was this guy,
there's a,
there was a pop star and flighty post punk pop star called Joe Jackson and none
of y'all have heard of it.
Cause all about 10 years old and my fault and Joe Jackson had this song and
which had the lyric I something like you can't get what you want and less,
you know what you want,
right?
You can't get your account,
get what you wanted us to know.
You know what you want.
And as a statement of logic,
that's false,
right?
It could be that what you want just drops into your lap without you knowing
about it.
All right?
But at the same as a strategy,
it's a pretty good idea.
It's a good idea to try and figure out what your goals are,
what you're trying to achieve before you go ahead and analyze the game.
All right,
so payoffs matter.
Let's put it in his version.
You can't guess
what do you want
till
you know
what you want.
Be Honest.
How many of you have heard of Joe Jackson?
Oh,
it makes me feel old.
Oh Man.
Okay.
It goes down every year.
All right,
so so far we've looked at this game as played by people who are evil goods and
we've lived with this game as played by people who are indignant angels.
But we can do something more interesting.
We can imagine playing this game on a sort of mix and match.
For example,
imagine this shouldn't be hard for most of you.
Imagine that you are an evil gets,
but you knew that the person you're playing against isn't indignant.
Angel might say,
again,
imagine that you know you're an evil gates,
but you know that the person you're playing against or with isn't indignant
angel.
What should you do in that case?
What should they be doing?
Who thinks you should choose alpha?
In that case,
it's half pound the room.
Again,
we can keep your hands up so,
so as you can see here,
all right,
who thinks she's out?
Who they should choose?
Beats are in that case.
Who's abstaining here?
I'm going to abstain in this class.
It's complete.
No.
Okay.
So we'll allow some extensions on the first day,
but not beyond today.
Let's have a look.
Let's analyze this combined game.
All right.
So what does this game look like?
It's an evil gates versus
and indignant angel.
All right,
add it.
We can put the payoff matrix together by combining the matrices we had before.
So in this case,
this is me as always.
This is my,
the column player.
Okay?
My payoffs are going to be what?
My payoff is going to the evil.
Get payoffs.
So they come from the matrix up there.
So if I'm gonna have to help me reading it off there,
that's a zero three a minus one and a one.
All right.
My opponent or my partners pay offs come from the Indigo Angel May Matrix.
So they come from here.
There is zero,
a minus three,
a minus one and the one they want to see how I constructed that sort of just to
remind you again,
the first payoff is the role players pay off.
In this case the evil gets high and the second payoff is the column players pay
off.
In this case the indignant angel.
Hi,
well now we've set it up as a matrix.
Let's try again that question I asked before.
Suppose your the role player here,
you're the evil get.
Those are your payoffs.
You're playing against them,
the angel,
what would you do?
Right?
So once again,
no attention at this time.
Who would choose alpha?
Let's have a show of hands again.
Keep your hands up a second.
And who would choose beats that.
I have very few beaters but most of the album I'll find I think is the right
answer here.
But why?
Why?
Why is Alpha the right answer here?
So yeah.
Can we get,
can we get this guy here?
Yeah,
it's the dominant strategy.
Good.
Actually,
nothing has changed from the game.
We started with the fact they changed the other guy's payoffs didn't matter
here.
Alpha was dominant before it dominated.
Beat it before and it still dominates.
Peter.
Let's just check.
If my opponent chooses alpha and I choose Alpha,
I get zero pizza.
I get minus one.
So Alpha would be better if my opponent chooses bita and I choose Alpha,
I get three beach,
I get one.
Once again,
Alpha's better.
So as before Alpha does better than pizza for me,
regardless of what the other person does.
Alpha dominates.
Bita,
what was the first lesson of the class?
What was the first lesson of the class?
Writing out please.
Right,
right.
So you should all have been choosing in this game.
You all should be using your,
you all should have chosen alpha.
All right,
so the one person didn't,
we'll let him offer today.
Okay.
So how far dominate speeds in here.
All right,
let's flip things around.
Yeah,
right.
I suppose now harder to imagine,
but it's try it.
Suppose now that you are an indignant angel
and you're playing against the new new this,
you're playing against an evil again.
Great.
You're in a demon angel,
so you have the pay offs that are still there and you're playing against the
evil gate,
which is the power we covered up,
but we'll reproduce them that's produced that Matrix.
By the way,
this has been the sound like a wrestling match.
I don't mean it to,
let's try here.
Alpha Beta Alpha Pizza pass me.
All right,
so my pay off this time are the indigo angel.
Payoffs are minus zero minus one minus three and one and my opponents pay offs
are,
what would it be my pals before they come from the other matrix as a show,
right?
They come from this matrix so there can be zero minus one three one
zero minus one three one.
Okay to be,
I think the second payoff from that Matrix and made it the second payoff in this
matrix.
Okay,
everyone.
See how I did that?
Once again,
the role player is the first pay off and the column player is the other.
All right.
What should you do in this case?
You're the indignant angel.
You're playing games is evil gates.
What should you do?
Write down in your notepad what you do.
Show it to your neighbors.
You can't cheat,
you can't cheat,
but you'll be shamed.
Shame in front your neighbor
and uh,
raise your hands.
All that juicy it.
Raise your hand.
Keep them up if you chose Alpha now.
And how about if you shows beaten now?
So why don't you beat as mostly Alphas?
Well,
let's see it.
Let's reason this through a second.
This Alpha,
does my Alpha dominate my bita?
No.
In fact,
Alpha doesn't dominate.
Be Deaf for me.
It hasn't only been,
it might.
If,
if my pair of shoes is Alpha,
then Alpha gets me zero Beta minus three.
So Alpha does better.
But if my patch,
who's his beats that then I'll forget to me minus one beat against me.
One.
In this case,
Peter is better at better.
So once again,
as we saw before,
Alpha is better against Alpha beaters.
Get better against Peta.
There's no dominance going on here.
Nevertheless,
at least 90% of you chose Alpha here,
and that's the right answer.
Why?
Why should you choose Alpha here?
Somebody who we met.
Who can we get the guy with the beard here?
Yeah.
Wait,
wait for the Mike [inaudible].
Great.
We'd acknowledge that Alpha is a dominant strategy from my apartment,
so we must choose based upon or knowing that my part is going to choose alpha.
Good,
good,
good.
And your name is Henry.
So Henry saying,
sure,
I don't have a domination strategy.
My Alpha doesn't dominate my beta.
But look at my opponents.
My opponents Alpha dominates Herbie to,
if I choose Alpha and she chooses Alpha to get zero [inaudible],
she gets minus one.
Alpha is better if I choose bita.
If she's Alpha actually gets three B.
So one against,
again,
Alpha is better for my opponents.
Alpha Dominates Bita.
So by,
by thinking about my opponent,
I putting myself on my opponents shoes,
I realize that she has a dominant strategy alpha,
she's going to choose alpha.
And my best response against Alpha is to choose alpha myself.
All right,
so here
this time my Alpha does not dominate.
Fisa
bought my peers.
Yeah,
my peers just choice of Alpha Dominique's her choice I possible slice of pizza,
so she will shoes.
She will choose our flat and once I know that she's going to choose Alpha,
it's clear that I should choose Alpha and get zero rather than Bita and get
minus three
so I
should choose Alpha Olsen.
All right.
Okay,
so now we've seen four different combinations.
We've seen a case where an evil gate was playing an evil get when endemic nature
will find it and did an angel and we've seen both the flips of those that you
will get the angel and they didn't win against evil.
Get.
Why are we doing this?
Because there's an important lesson here.
What's the lesson here?
The lesson is comes from this game that a great way to analyze game,
a great way to get used to the idea of strategic thinking.
Perhaps even the essence of strategic thinking is the ability to put yourself in
someone else's shoes,
figure out what their payoffs are and trying to figure out what they're going to
do.
All right,
so the big lesson of this game is,
okay,
I forgot what number we're up to.
I guess there's best in for,
I think less than four is
put yourself
in others shoes
and
try to figure out,
okay,
what they will do.
Yeah,
and then the sentence,
this is the first difficult lesson of the class.
It's easy to spot when a strategy is dominant,
more or less.
It's pretty easy to write,
to figure out.
You have to know about your own payoffs,
but the hard thing in life is getting you to come out of your own selves a bet
rising.
It's quote,
not all about you.
You've got to put yourself in other people's shoes different on what they care
about and what they're going to try and do.
So you can respond well to that right now.
While we're here,
let's just mention the things we get more complicated in a world where I don't
actually know the payoffs of my opponent.
It's much easier to figure out my own payoffs than to figure out my opponent's
payoffs,
right?
I might not know what that I'm playing someone who isn't evil gates or an
indignant angel.
So I'm going to have to figure out what the odds are of that in doing this
exercise.
And I guess that's what we're going to come back to that idea to way at the end
of the class,
that's getting a bit ahead of ourselves,
but we'll get there.
No,
turns out that this game,
this prisoner's dilemma with the Alphas and pieces or essentially the same game
has been played many,
many,
many times in experiments.
Alright?
So out there in the real world,
I think we can do this yet out there in the real world,
when they do these experiments,
they find out that roughly 70% of people choose alpha and roughly 30%
choose pizza,
roughly almost a third shoe speeder.
And what do we think is going on?
Why I,
so that's a third of the people who seem to be choosing a dominator strategy or
is it,
what's going on there?
Why?
Why do you think,
why do you think that 30% of people are choosing
I choosing pizza?
Anybody who can,
can we catch this guy here?
They might be motivated by the fact that every,
every person who chooses beat a raises the a B average.
It could be moral people.
They could be one possibility.
Is this 30% of people in the real world and choose pizza?
I just deiced people.
All right.
What else could it be?
I know this might be changing the game a little bit,
but if you ever expected to play the same game with the partner,
all right,
so they have more.
They could be thinking they're going to play again,
like long run payoffs are greater if you choose Beta every time.
So they could be that.
They think this is actually the,
the
just at the experimental,
they think this is a multi shot game,
not a one shot game.
Good.
What else could it be?
What's the simplest explanation?
What's the other obvious explanation?
Just don't understand.
They could just be stupid,
right?
It could be,
right,
right.
We're not to say that in costly.
Right,
right,
right.
Let's be honest here.
When we say experiments in the real world and game theory or the ones you read
about in the New York Times,
the real world when it comes to experiments,
uh,
on in economics really means undergraduates at the University of Arizona.
All these,
I mean,
I'm not making that up.
We just does.
They all are.
But I don't know anything about any of you from Arizona.
I Dunno.
I don't know whether the average Undergrad at the University of Arizona just has
a sunny personality or whether they spend too long in the sun.
I just don't know what to do this.
Right.
We call re distinguished from this.
All right.
How about at Yale?
What do,
what's our numbers here?
How about in this class?
You don't do you a Mike here at your colleague here?
Yeah,
so two 38 yeah.
All this is Yale versus 36.
So even even at my level of arithmetic,
that's a lot less than 30% right?
That's more like less than 15% no,
it's about 15% I guess.
Alright.
So two 30,
six to 38 shows Alpha and 36 chose Beta.
Now there's a,
there's one more lesson in this class and there's going to be,
there's gonna be a whole lot,
but this isn't end of the class.
But one more lesson to take home.
You guys are going to be playing games among each other today and until whatever
it is,
December 7th,
whatever it is,
the end of the end of,
uh,
at the end of term.
Alright?
So look around each other.
You may get to know each other a bets,
right?
And what did we learn today about you guys?
The lesson here,
lesson five is Yale students.
Ah,
evil,
right?
Be Aware of that when you're playing games.
All right,
I want to play one more game today are in the remaining minutes.
It doesn't matter if we finish earlier,
but I wanna try and get this game at least started.
So do you all have game number two in front of you?
I want just to look at this real reading that over I can.
I also make sure you've all got your legal forms and you you're going to sign.
Don't walk away with are legal forms you,
we need to get those connected in.
So at the end of talking about this game,
I'm going to collect in both the second game and for the class and also the
legal form,
right?
If you don't have a legal form or if you've lost it or something,
it's online.
All right.
It's online.
All right,
let's have a look at that second game.
I'll read it out for you.
Game to pick a number.
Everyone got this?
Anyone not got this?
I haven't got it
without showing your neighbor what you're doing.
Put in the box below a whole number between one and a hundred whole number.
He 100 integer.
We will calculate the average number chosen in the class.
The winner in this game is the person whose number is closest to two thirds
times the average in the class.
Again,
the winner is the person whose number is closest to two thirds times the average
number in the class.
And the winner will win $5 minus the difference in pennies between her choice
and that two thirds of the average.
I'm just,
once you've understood this,
let me do an example on the board.
Got One more board.
That's good.
So managing two or three people in the class
and imagine that they chose 25 five and 60 all right,
so 25 plus five plus 60 is 90 people from,
feel free to correct my reference because it's often wrong.
90 right?
And 92 thirds of 92 thirds of 92 thirds of,
whoops,
whoops.
Uh,
what do we need to start again?
I need to divide it by three to get the average,
right.
So the average,
the average is 30 thank you.
Somebody shutting out,
right?
So total is 90 the average is 30 am I right so far?
All right,
so two thirds of the average,
two thirds of the average is 20.
I'm looking desperately the ta,
is that right?
Okay.
All right.
So the average is 30 and two thirds of the averages.
20.
All right.
So who's the winner?
Which,
which number would have,
would,
would've won here?
25 would have won 25 would've been the closest.
And what would they have one?
They'd have won five bucks minus 5 cents for a total of four 95
right now to make this interesting.
Let's play this for real.
So this course relies on me having brought some money and be able to do this
without dislodging the microphone.
All right,
so I'm gonna see if I have,
sorry about that.
I'm going to see if I have enough money to do this class room.
When we play this game in the,
uh,
in the old days,
during the.com boom with the MBA students,
you have to put 50 bucks on the table to get them interested.
Graduate Students,
5 cents.
Do it.
Okay,
so this is a,
that some bloke with a bid on this one?
Yeah,
this is okay.
This is Lincoln.
Apparently Lincoln apparently.
Who Knew Lincoln.
Okay.
All right,
so this is a $5 note and I'm going to put it,
sorry about that again.
I'm going to put it in an envelope.
I'm not cheating anybody,
right?
I'm not in the no magic tricks here and that you're going to be a prize for
this,
for this game,
and we better give this to someone we trust.
All right,
so prize for one 59 who do you guys trust?
Yeah,
the camera guy.
Okay.
Jude,
we know Jews is going to be that next week or I'm getting it to Jude.
He can come see this on camera.
People at home,
but I'm giving it to Jude.
Okay.
I'm going to put it here and Judah.
Judah justice,
therefore shop next week with the prize.
Okay.
All right.
I think we should give it to the guy at the back.
Who is the moral guy?
Who is our moral guidance about?
What is it?
All right.
Wait,
wait,
nevermind.
I get it.
We'll give it to you.
We know g is going to be here.
All right.
Has everyone put a number down?
Any questions your questions?
Yes.
Just shout them out to me.
We only have one $5 bill.
Does that to be one unique winter and if so,
how is that determined if we have multiple people who will?
That's a good question.
If there's multiple winners we'll divide it,
but we'll make sure everyone that has a positive wedding.
Okay.
Good question.
Given the number of people in the room then maybe multiple rentals.
I except that I,
that possibility has everyone written down a number now?
Alright,
so hand your numbers to the end of the road.
Don't go yet.
And you know what I'm saying?
The row before you go,
I want five things from you.
All right.
I want to know the five lessons from this class,
right?
Tell him,
tell me what you learned.
What were the five lessons?
Without looking at your notes,
what were the five lessons?
Anybody worth?
Shout out one of the lessons.
Yes.
Madam,
don't play a strictly dominated strategy.
Anything else?
Yes.
Yale students who evil to lessons down.
Three to go.
The guy over here.
Yep.
Rational choice can lead rational choices,
can lead to bad outcomes.
We put it more graphically before,
but that's fine.
Too.
More outcome,
more.
Put yourself in other people's shoes and I'm missing one.
I'm not going to do what I'm missing now.
Ah,
you can't get your wall that you could,
but it's a good idea to figure out what you want.
We'll try and get what you want.
Five things you learned today,
hand in your numbers and the legal forms,
and I'll see you on Monday.